cours aux golgoht l'habile provient
depuis 20 ans tête de liste ou
simplement villes pro se lance en
politique il a mené sa réunion publique
vendredi 7 février
les candidats me paraissent pas à la
hauteur les programmes qu'ils présentent
ils sont flous sont pas très claires et
la ville à moi à mon sens méritait autre
chose mérite une transformation la ville
de wimereux devient une ville dortoir et
un abandon de la culture le candidat de
53 ans ou être réanimé la ville et le
théâtre fermé mais aussi créer un musée
pour la ville ou encore l'aménagement de
l'ale de l'école jacques gillet en une
grande école de musique l'éducation un
point important pour ce candidat il faut
se structurer et
et élargir construire agrandir notre
collège et
il faut que la ville rayonne un
rayonnement qui pourrait être celui
d'une pièce kouros golgoht l'abe
souhaite instaurer une monnaie locale
il mesure phare que je dirais pour les
commerces ou de soutenir la création
d'une monnaie locale à villepreux je
pense que l'exemple dans les yvelines
n'existe pas remuer en france ça a très
bien marché
le candidat souhaite une augmentation
des effectifs de la police municipale
parmi les autres projets étudiés 1 est
la priorité de ce candidat qui est aussi
médecin chirurgien spécialiste en orl la
santé il faut faire à mon avis hein
c'est pas mon avis c'est le projet une
maison de garde qui serait ouverte 7
jours sur 7 de 8h30 à à minuit elle la
prochaine réunion publique de coureuses
golgoht lab est prévue le 22 février